好 今天台股真的是光通閃閃的
非常亮眼的一天
但是能不能延續呢
我們還是會覺得
如果早一點進場佈局的
創新高的有恭喜各位
但如果現在手上報的股票
還在比較低位階的
我們就來聽聽看
王伯不一定是要送暖
但是要送信心了對不對
像CPU其實看高做低啦
還蠻多談的沒有非常高的
再來800伏創量產
其實BBU之前的漲勢也都不太連貫
可是光寶科真的給了大家希望
誰會是下檔光寶客
其實今天的體感溫度蠻高的
我記得7月29號
我還跟朱老師在這一邊
冷收收的
還提醒大家說要趕快把握機會
可是大家想一想才一個月
才一個月
然後你看到很多的股票就這樣上來
之前可能在等解套
現在有很多的股票已經開始
開始在數鈔票
所以我的想法說
如果大家再往接下來的行情看
9月底有
9月有季底作帳
9月底
然後第四季常常都是漲多跌少
然後延續到圓越行情
搞不好
搞不好這就是
跌下來之後
先蹲後跳
搞不好是大家最好的機會
但是我們還是要看一下
到底有哪些什麼
有哪些已經表態了
那表態出來之後有哪些股票
我們可以把它掌握起來
那當然
當然現在市場最大的幾個訊息
一個是華許
華許要在傑森後要演講
可是我之前往往看那個華許
有講過一段話
他說
升息不是唯一的解方
所以我們就靜觀其面
看他要講什麼
另外就是輝達
輝達財報
說輝達財報之後
現在趕快
趕快推出那個Vera Rubin
來幫大家打打氣你知道嗎
所以我的看法
我的看法說
如果我們接下來要延續
那個季縣這一邊
開始要往上攻的行情
我們還是用產業面的角度來看
那當然怎麼樣
輝達出來說了
交換器要開始放量
然後怎樣 他也跟你講
接下來VR之後 VR Rubin之後
那當然什麼 AI的電力
那個大戰要開打
所以我覺得這兩個主題
一個BBUH VDC還有一個CPU
我們今天就來幫大家追蹤
那當然其實如果我們看台積電
台積電之前張小強也講了
那個所謂的那個COOP
就是接下來的關鍵字
那所以我個人認為
其實這個都是大家要注意的
那當然很多的股票
很多的股票慢慢上來
特別我們如果從美國的股市來講
這一次台股比較強
對
台灣的那個細光子
CPU概念比較強
是 平行而論
因為之前這些股票
衝上去的時候是他們在帶
然後帶了一大段之後
結果這些股票在跌
這些股票跌的時候
反而我們的什麼
我們的老CPU跟新CPU
包含像所謂聯亞
跟所謂大力光衝上去
但是要提醒大家
包含像Vertiv跟BE
這個是跟電有關係的
那這個B1大家要特別留意
裴洛西不是買了B1嗎
還買了選擇權
國會的女股神
美國國會的女股神
她買B1啦
所以我覺得說
其實她可能怎麼樣
可能也是看好電
所以我認為啦
我認為其實這個都是
我們接下來在台股裡面要去思考
要去面對佈局的啦
那當然CPU我講很多了
我們再來看一下
輝達的所謂電力大戰要開打了
以前怎麼樣
以前那個相關的那個電的
那個相關的組件
全部都塞在所謂的那個什麼
所謂的那個AI那個機櫃裡面但問題來啦如果你現在把所有東西都塞進去的話會產生一個狀況是塞不進去然後散熱的問題對所以現在現在他就把那個電力的機櫃
把它給獨立出來
以前叫塞卡
現在大家把它叫成PowerRick
所以我認為
我認為如果說
接下來大家考量到
所謂的AI的發展
然後還要一個穩定高品質的電的話
這個難怪
難怪台灣的這些廠商受惠
所以這是輝達的規劃
然後這個是我們的三本柱大電
是 當然我們都說
大電現在的漲勢是落後光寶科
但是今天也是有小表現了
平常請講
因為之前在漲的時候它還帶
然後後來跌下來的時候
它好像還在
慢慢的從低檔低位階拉上來
我們之前有送暖過
它有小漲上來
至少低點沒有破
那就有看它的規劃
其實公司派其實基本上還是蠻正面
倒是我們之前
也是一直一直送暖的光寶科
是
嚇一跳
真的嚇一跳
沒想到最近強成這個樣子
因為看到快到300
想說300關卡嘛
照樣給他衝過去
不要說300
那時候100多 200的時候
大家都想說這個股票不會動
股性太差
法說會變法會
那時候大家都很
對他很沒責
可是後來就是一大段
好 大力光也是我們一直非常看好的
王伯曾經也在大力光修正的時候
送暖過
從那個時候到今天創新高
已經漲了59個百分點
聯亞也是這一波
零化音的大贏家
漲了三成
哇 這聯亞已經
今天漲快要回新高了
看起來這個應該不是什麼問題
雙箭頭啦 雙箭頭啦
其實那時候我們在講
大力光的時候說
其實它切入所謂CPU
那特別FAU這一段
我們想說
現在市場上就是一成嘛
它可以做到四成
那時候我們討論說
因為它根本就還沒有貢獻
對啊 其實今天就算
重返農藥創高
還是沒有貢獻
還沒有量成
但問題來
問題來就是說
其實這就是一個題材
那當然如果說
接下來輝達台積電要
所謂加速的光進同退
那當然什麼
當然他的技術是領先的
所以大家就想說
為什麼大綠光
最近的動作越來越大
那當然越來越大的話
當然可能胸有成竹
因為他列地
我想今天這個
對他注意很大
所以我覺得就沿著
五日線操作
那當然如果是
朱老師的話
他可能會提醒你
就是說這種股票
你不要去放空
你就順勢操作
然後回後買上漲
回後買上漲
其實有時候我們也是
跟在朱老師旁邊
學一些技術分析
兩家投信都非常的支持
其實有時候投信會買龍頭
會買領頭羊
所以我接下來
接下來這是所謂的新CPU部分
那老CPU部分其實
那個漲跌更分歧
新CPU其實有一檔帶一檔
那個大力光上去
那個玉金光就上去
但是老CPU就有點分歧
等一下我們來看有沒有
比較可以值得注意的
然後看高做低的
那當然這個是我們在看的
兩個箭頭先把它抓出來
兩個箭頭抓出來之後
我們就要看籌碼
然後看高做低
比較有趣的
其實我們看
這個都有千張大戶在增加持股
所以平行而論
投信之前棄手CPU
投信回來之後
其實你可以發覺說
不管是外資也好
或者是400張大物 千張大物
的確有在琢磨
那當然我的看法就是說
那這個趕長
那當然什麼
弟弟妹妹我們也要注意那個哥哥姐姐衝快一點沒關係弟弟妹妹後面也要上但是這一次我們沒有把光盛放上來為什麼其實光盛不錯你不講我還沒注意到光盛的古杏
我之前送軟送到覺得說
光盛的古杏好難送
前兩天也有送一根掌停板
對
那所以我們以前的領頭羊是光盛
後來我就說
應該我們是要看聯亞
聯亞大力光
對對對
那當然啦
如果聯亞上去啦
波羅威華
那當然光盛也會上去
所以大家也可以注意啦
注意說股性能不能夠變好
這比較重要
那有時候股性變好
那當然它的股價會比較活潑
好 今天來送暖是環宇KY
雖然今天也是漲停板
但是可以看得出來
很明顯位階反彈的沒有很高
對 因為你看嘛
這邊還是一個均線的一個糾結區嘛
它沒有說像這樣直接衝上去
我認為啦
其實它有一個優勢就是美國製造
另外就是800G的PD
它是市佔全球第一啦
那當然前五月的營收年增
45.74%
前7月的營收年增
那當然我認為
接下來當然我們要看
數字會不會一直進來
那如果數字進來的話
因為這也是今年的腰股之一
就是讓它能夠什麼
能夠再
看能不能夠再腰起來
如果能夠再腰起來
其實很多股票
就一檔一檔上來
那當然剛才像那個重達KY
說這個重達KY
就突然跳上來
嚇一跳
所以KY股
大家可能也可以開始留意
那一樣先區間
先區間
大家就把這個區間記起來
包含像7月16號的高點
還有那個8月25號的低點
先區間一段一段做
看能不能越站越穩
這一檔說真的
數字還沒有進來
好 就是有點在幫我們做一些延伸
對不對 對 延伸
因為現在新舊CPU都有話題
對對對
那因為上半年EPS-2.85
可以都有點多耶
對 不大好看 不大好看
但是問題啦 問題來說
因為它是做設備
那接下來當時要提醒大家說
它那個設備的出貨量會不會提高
然後營收獲率會不會拉上來
它還在黏線啊
很慘很慘
疊慘了 225-187
其實它之前也曾經
因為那個所謂CPU的題材
也拉過一段
但是你看這樣疊下來
也都不客氣的啦
現在高票一年
起來也是狠狠
然後下來也狠
那我注意到這檔股票是因為
它要參加下個月的國際半導體展
然後它要展示什麼
展示包含像LAN還有FAU的光彩檢
因為它本身就是所謂的設備廠
還有PIC晶片的測試設備
那另外它是針對1.6T 3.2T
推出主動是對位矽光紙偶光貼合機
所以沒有辦法
如果說我們在看那個發展的過程當中
我們當然很期待說
它的營收獲利能夠馬上進來
如果說營收獲利沒有辦法馬上進來的話
它至少有一個所謂設備的題材的話
你就放到口袋裡面
然後等到它數字出來
甚至說我們看到什麼
投信大戶開始進來的時候
因為有時候春江水奶壓先知
我們可能划得比較慢一點
但是處理大戶還有
投信可能快一點
那你就可以留意啦
那當然這檔股票就提供給大家
因為位階低
位階低也曾經標過
對而且大家那時候在看
也不知道它在標什麼
但是它有CPO題材
而且設備廠商照來說
如果有這樣韌列進來
要轉虧為營不會太難
對 很快很快
那接下來就是我們剛才提到
因為以前都塞在那個AI的機櫃裡面
現在把它獨立出來
有一個所謂的電力櫃
那如果是電力櫃
還有包含像所謂800VDC的
那個相關的題材的話
那當然我們會什麼
HVDC BBU一個組合然後公力半導體一個組合一個所謂的相關的內容那我們就來看有什麼注意都有領頭羊重點是都有領頭羊HVDC BBU的領頭羊是光寶科
然後呢
之前的那個公立半導體
是所謂的那個什麼
強茂台辦
今天都這樣體驗
但是之前疊下來速度也很快
對 那所以我認為
我認為我們就來看有沒有機會
看起來怎麼樣
看起來數字都還不錯
慢慢進來了
然後外資跟投信也有琢磨
所以這就是我們必須想說
是不是說有的股票衝上來之後
包含像順打
順打接拉漲
漲停辦
是不是一個一個帶一個
那這種股票如果在低檔
低位接我們就可以注意
好 整體都是跟電有相關的
這絕對是必備的
其實還有很多
為什麼我說這是一個set
這個是一個set
其實還有很多
大家可以自己做功課
也許我們沒有列進去
也許你的股票還沒有動
那你就先把它列進去
然後去檢視一下
有沒有發動的那個機會
對 所以我覺得這個族群性也蠻大
所以有時候
當族群性出來的時候
那個助長的力量會更大
會更大
那當然之前我們講光寶科
之前其實在這邊講很多次
我們就沒有一一列出來
但現在它已經不需要你奉暖了
其實那個時候
那個有時候
因為我們在選股的過程當中
其實來理財達人秀
我們都要很認真
都要费尽心力
那头发越来越少
然后就想说找一些好股票
然后那时候真的找不到一些
比较活泼的股票的时候
我就常常把光宝科拿出来讲
挡一下是不是
挡一下挡一下
没想到后来挡成标股啊
对不对
这个也是天道酬勤
好
挡成标股了
我们就要换下一档光宝科了
一样啦一样就
股价就是顺势操作了
而且比较特别的是
投信最近为什么在这个位置只买
你看这边卖到什么样的程度
就开始买了
所以這檔股票大家還是可以留意
我覺得光寶科應該
延均線操作
對 後世可期
那這檔股票其實之前我們講過
新勝利
衝上來差一點過高
差一點過高
那這個就是注意嘛 對不對
那個朱老師講的回後買上漲
他有沒有回 他有回
那如果回後買上漲
成交量要出來的話
而且大戶的持股又是不離不棄
明顯增加
對 那我覺得新勝利就有去
而且我上次在講新勝利
我是拿他跟順打
對
因為這兩檔很活潑
然後新勝利其實上半年的獲利是高於順達
然後現在的新勝利跟順達的股價差了快100塊
所以我認為今天順達拉上去
然後是不是說新勝利也有機會勾上
但是如果就形態來講
順達的位階是比較低
因為新勝利這一波有先拉動
對 先拉動一段
那我覺得大家可以留意
那另外就是說如果要從公率半導體公立原
因為看到強茂台辦都漲點
順德 另外一檔順德
今天也拉上去
那我覺得因為
這檔股票其實有點悶
還在黏啊
對 那我之前有提醒過
因為大戶的持股是沒有鬆動的
然後它的主要的大股東就是國劇
就是國劇集團 同心店 凱美
然後要漲價15%
所以我的看法 我的看法是說
不如怎麼樣 守株待兔
這種股票也可以留意
好 都是幫我們找相對
像上次我還印象很深
跟順達比以獲利來說
但是因為漲了一段
回後買上漲 大戶在增加
貿達就等他表態吧
就等他表態啦
我覺得就良性輪動的過程當中
就是火種一個一個
把它點燃上來
我覺得目前看來
接下來的行情應該滿有戲的
好 滿有戲的
非常謝謝王博
謝謝趙